- So you brought wine today,
first of all thank you.
And secondly, this is your label
and it's with Nina Dobrev, right?
- Yes, yes, so Nina and I-
- Thank you Marcel.
- Oh, thank you so much,
thank you, thank you.
- I'm about to go on vacation to Italy,
so we'll just drink to that.
- Oh yes, just kind of get
started early. I love it.
- I'm gonna try it.
- My best friend, Nina, and I,
we started Fresh Vine Wine, and
you guys are gonna love this
because it is a premium
wine from Napa Valley,
but it's low-carb, low-calorie, low-sugar.
And honestly, we've done
so well since we launched.
We're gonna be in all 50
states by July, which-
- Wait, you've only been
out for about a year, right?
- We launched in 2021,
but we, in one year,
we got all 50 states.
Which, that does not happen.
- Wow, it's really good.
- So, Whole Foods, Total
Wines, it's everywhere.
And also, again, not
compromising on how good it is,
cause I've tasted some of
the other low-calorie ones,
and I'm not trying to knock,
but I'm also tryin' to promote-
- But also, something sometimes
just doesn't taste good.
- This is delicious. Exactly.
- We're not knockin' em, we're just...
You grew up in a Mormon family,
which I love your family.
I actually met your whole family one time,
I feel like in a hallway
in an awards show,
and I was like, your mother
should sell her eggs.
They're all beautiful, it's like, what?
Anyway, but, so wine was probably
never a part of your household.
I'm southern Baptist, so
sometimes, whenever I grew up
it was like, no dancing,
no singing, (indistinct).
Very Footloose-
- Very Footloose.
- Very Footloose, that's hilarious,
didn't even mean to do it.
But when did you start living wines,
since you didn't grow up around it?
- Well, when I was 21, I
actually ended up dating
your former host, Ryan.
- Ryan Seacrest, yeah.
- And so we dated and
he's very much into wine.
- Is he? I didn't know that.
- Oh yeah, he's gotta a
winery in Napa and in Italy.
- What?
- Yeah, that was my first-
- He has so many jobs.
- Yes.
- Okay, keep going, I'm sorry.
- That's a total sidebar, but yes.
- Yes, yes.
- He introduced me to wine,
and what was so interesting
is, because I didn't drink
because growing up LDS,
it was usually associated with
partying and getting drunk.
But this was an education,
and I'm such a geek.
I love to learn things.
- I love learning.
- And so it was like, he
taught me all the different,
how to smell and taste,
and swirl the glass.
- Pairing is important as well.
- It was very, it felt very cool.
And then, I was, how do I
take that, what I learned
and put it into something good
and share it with all of you?
- Yes, something wonderful,
even Jesus was into this.
(audience laughing)
- Absolutely.
- This is God's plan, not mine.
- Cheers.
- Thank you Jesus.